feels like every year at this time Matt
Ryan kind enough to join us the Falcons
quarterback just out of practice how are
you Matt how are you I'm doing great I'm
doing great
what is it what was accomplished today
in practice we just polished some stuff
up we've got the preseason game to
tomorrow so today was kind of just a
little bit of a walkthrough of what
we're gonna do tomorrow night kind of
getting our first look at Kansas City
this time of the year you don't really
gain plan much so getting our first look
at some of the defenses and situations
we might see tomorrow night so I thought
it was a good little tune-up for us
before we get into the dome tomorrow
night how much are you gonna play that's
a good question
we you don't know I don't know yet I
don't know yet usually how its operated
for us is kind of locals tonight before
the game we kind of get a rundown on all
right you're gonna be a series 2 Series
or 10 15 plays whatever it is but you
know it's the typical for us this time
of the year maybe a couple of series
we'll see what it is you lost to the
Jets last week what did you see out of
Sam Donald I thought he did a good job
you know I tell on what they were doing
I thought he extended some plays really
well both inside and outside the pocket
and I thought he moved you know pretty
smoothly inside the pocket so you know
it's hard to take too much from from
these day long you know everything I saw
is encouraging I think he's off to a
good start what do you remember about
your first couple of games in pre-season
oh man they were a blank you know I
remember the first touchdown pass I
threw was against the Jacksonville
Jaguars where down there was in the
first game and I was in a dead wrong
spot I was supposed to be against the
coverage we were going Ron Reed threw
karate white people caught a touchdown
so it was like you know just keeping
your head above water speaking of the
Jags jamming Ramsey had some comments on
NFL quarterbacks and you made the list
their congratulations javi a
subscription to GQ Matt I don't
have a subscription to DQ but obviously
you cannot hear about the story and your
reaction is you know what a plate for
eleven years and so you know I've heard
my fair share of trash-talking from a
lot of different people and if this
stuff kept me up at night I probably
want to be doing what I'm doing so I
don't pay too much mind to it I'm about
winning games and I'm about being the
absolute best player to activity so that
that's kind of my thoughts on it yeah so
Jalen Ramsey said that Matt was
overrated how do you win MVP than your
coach leaves and you have a terrible
year he still has Julio Jones it just
doesn't make sense to me now the Falcons
played the Jags August 25th is part of
the preseason is is that where you lobby
to play a little bit more mad than that
we've got more important and bigger
goals to accomplish they've been trying
to make a statement in the third
preseason game did you what was your
reaction when the Falcons were on the
clock and Calvin Ridley is the name
that's called the Alabama wide receiver
I was fired up I think with Julio being
on the team we've seen plenty of Alabama
games you know the night before in
hotels and of course with those games so
you know other than Alabama fans I
probably saw as many other games as
anybody and you know saw how talented he
was and the kind of player he was so I
was excited about it and you know as
he's gotten here and been able to work
with us I'm even more excited I think
he's a talented guy I think he's a you
know really good fit for our system
opposite of Julio muhammad's who you
know I expect him to do big things for
us this year I think he's gonna have a
really good rookie season well it's not
like you can say hey can we watch the
Boston College game we didn't have the
appropriate channels I think at the
hotels were staying at to watch the BC
game do you watch Hard Knocks I have
watched it in the past I have not seen
an episode
this year I've got two twin boys at home
so my time doing tini is is not as much
as it used to be how old are the boys
they're about six months oh my goodness
yeah so it's it's a fun and exciting
time for us right now
and you name one Julio and one Jones is
that right yeah they're both their
middle names are Julio Jones Nadi white
Tony Gonzalez I tried to include all
those guys are you allowed to name are
you involved in the process or do you
get one and then your wife got to name
one that you're involved in the process
but I'm not really involved in the
process it was I guess it was a
collaborative effort well what are their
names
Marshall and Johnny so yeah Marshalls
the order of the twin boys by about
seven minutes so Falken Manziel I like
it I like that last time you looked at
watch that divisional playoff game
against the Eagles that you lost a
handful of days after the playoff loss
but you know seeing cut-ups as we've
gone through out the season plays and
situations have come up you know a
handful of times that's row - Julio
would you have done anything differently
just to throw you might have had a
different play but just that throw did
you put it where you needed to put it
yeah I thought an opportunity but you
know we all have to you know in
situations do things didn't have done
anything different you know the play
call is what it is roll out and give you
know our best player an opportunity we
just you know collectively didn't make
make enough plays throughout the game to
get it done but I don't think we would
have changed that play at the end Matt
it's good to talk to you and good luck
with the boys not only your Falcons but
the little boys at home we appreciate
your time as always
you got it thanks Dan appreciate it
that's Matt Ryan Falcons quarterback
he's played elevenses
does that seem like wow that doesn't
seem right that blew by 41 thousand
yards two hundred and sixty touchdowns
then we just all said and done what
you're gonna have McLovin fifty five
thousand and three hundred touchdowns
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]